also das vielleicht wirklich mit abstand
die heftigste achterbahnfahrt meines
lebens hey was geht ab märz bekommen
beim ein video ganz kurz hier die ansage
heute geht es nämlich im freizeitpark es
ist der größte freizeitpark in amerika
das weiß schon ob es der größte der welt
ist muss ich noch herausfinden er ist
auf jeden fall mega groß da gibt es nur
achterbahn
wir haben wir spontan tickets gekauft
und fahren jetzt mein ich hab gedacht
drehe ich hier kurz im block nehmen euch
mit mal gucken wie es wird achterbahn
fahren mache ich mir ja gerne
wahrscheinlich die meisten von euch auf
und ja jetzt müssen wir das jetzt läuten
wenn man auf jeden fall mal wieder mehr
gutes wetter und das hier hinter mir
kann man tun kann ist übrigens unser
hotel haben wir ganz spontan gebucht und
ist eigentlich megageil also aber diese
bahn sehen krank aus leute wir sind da
haben gerade schon die achterbahn
gereicht dass man mir scheißegal wenn
wir schon die achterbahn gesehen von der
straße und das sind mega viele und die
sind echt heftig aus also ich bin
wirklich mal gespannt wie vor allem das
gute ist ich glaube heute ist hier recht
wenig los das heißt wir kommen schnell
durch also jetzt was die man wir dachten
grad erstes ding dazu also haben hat
schon gesagt es ist wirklich krass und
noch mal eine steigerung sonst schon ich
weiß in letzter zeit öfter im europa
park und das sieht eigentlich noch mal
heftiger ausfallen wenn man da so
hinguckt gebt euch mal da oben diesen
looping
ja und das ist der eingang der ist
einfach komplett leer also ich habe auf
jeden fall mehr so leute wir sind drin
und das ist wirklich extrem mehr
[Musik]
ja meine karte
wir haben 18 jahren haben die also wir
haben hier bestimmt über zehn bis
fünfzehn achterbahn
aber ich muss jetzt eigentlich erstmal
was frühstücken wo gibt's hier frühstück
leute das ist recht so heftig hier ist
nichts los in deutschland jeder
freizeitpark sogar unter der woche ist
das voll mit schulklassen und hier alles
klar
ich bin mir nur dran nicht so sicher wie
ich die fahrt auf stehen dinge aufnehmen
kann ich versuche beim handy natürlich
aber wenn die zu gast sind dann kann man
das einfach nicht weil das handy sonst
wegfliegt ist letztes mit kollege von
mir passiert ist war da mal schauen so
leicht eigentlich wollen wir etwas
frühstücken aber wir fahren jetzt
einfach ein paar hier kann man direkt
durchgehend ausschnitt mit der leute ich
glaube dass für mich erst gar nicht mit
will jetzt einfach erstmal fahren
in deutschland wäre das eine stunde so
läutet die erste fahrt war auf jeden
fall krass das ding war in deutschland
geht ja eigentlich immer nur geradeaus
presse ist die stehen geblieben und ging
dann mit mega speed auch mal nach hinten
und jetzt gebt euch mal diese jurist
[Musik]
so leute jetzt wird erstmal hier
gegessen
ich habe keine ahnung was das ist
schmeckt auf jeden fall nicht so gut
aber ich habe heftig hunger
leute das ist so herzlich egal wo man
hinguckt überall sind ja einfach
achterbahn so leute als ich es geht es
in die green lantern oder so ich
versuche das diesmal mit dem handy mit
zu fühlen aber ich kann nichts
versprechen weil es ja auch mal ein
bisschen gefährlich die wieder auf ihren
vorlauf wieder echt krass aus so leute
jetzt haben wir uns doch gerade um
entschieden wir gehen jetzt erst hier in
diese blaue versuchst rats war mit dem
film ist natürlich überall verboten dass
ist ein bisschen schade aber man kann es
aber auch verstehen und wieder ist
diesmal absolut überlaufen hier ein paar
sekunden später
ich bin absolut fällig also das war die
heftigste achterbahn in der höhe war
also wirklich hätte ich mein handy dabei
gehabt das war so was von weggeflogen
also da bin ich mir sicher
also weil ich habe das gerade beim check
das problem ist wenn man mit dem handy
filmt sie sehen das auf den
videoaufnahmen die kann man allerdings
kaufen für 20 dollar würde ich schon
recht viel also da muss ich mal gucken
ob ich das ein- zweimal kaufen für euch
also an dieser stelle man dauert nach
oben
nein wir werden mal sehen
also das teil sieht auch krass aus denke
mal das geht auch über kopf die leute
jetzt geht's auch schnell hier rein
wir sind einfach jetzt die letzten
beiden hier einer und alle dürfen
mitfahren außer mir
[Musik]
das team hinter mir war krank das ding
ist das gibt's ja auch in deutschland
überall aber das ist doppelt so groß und
jetzt fahren wir wasser waren
hast du gestern gezogen als ich dieses
ding hier
wir warten noch kurz auf der bahn damit
ich euch zeigen kann
[Musik]
also leute auf geht's da rein ich kann
wahrscheinlich wieder nicht mit handy
filmen was will man hier raus
geschmissen aber wir schauen mal
naja leute also das war bis jetzt ja die
langweiligste aber jetzt geht es hier in
diese riesige orangene und danach gehen
wir in superman
das ist die man hängt da drin also hier
bin ich mal gespannt danach ist auf
jeden fall in superman das ist wo man so
richtig lange beschleunigt und dann
hochfährt und dann fällt mir runter das
habe ich am anfang an zeigen da versuche
ich wirklich mal mit dem handy zu filmen
werden wir sehen ob es klappt
[Musik]
jetzt war das mikro aus leute ich habe
gesagt das war wirklich das krasseste
also man fliegt dadurch wie superman du
bist halt so nach unten gelegen und im
vergleich zu deutschland ist es wirklich
viel viel heftiger keine ahnung ob das
in deutschland nicht erlaubt es sowas
aber ich finde es jetzt gleich mal
wieder hier durchaus und das gute ist
jesus überall komplett leer wir können
direkt in jeder bar du stellst du nicht
einmal zwei minuten an und dann geht's
ab
[Musik]
das recht kann also dass wir jetzt
wirklich mit abstand die heftigste
achterbahnfahrt
ai hat sie übrigens auch sehr geschneit
heute nacht die haben es schon ganz viel
mehr gekauft und dass dann mehr leute
der park der ist so überlaufen dass
brummt die richtig also die leute die
ich brüdern hier rein und jetzt geht es
hier in dieses weiter also
ja geschlossen da will ich jetzt aber 20
prozent von meinem ticket preis wieder
es wahrscheinlich wegen zu viel leuten
monate jetzt bin ich mal wirklich nicht
sparen das video das teil heißt superman
und beschleunigt erstmal auf 150 km/h
und geht dann hoch und wieder runter 170
km h hier also ich glaub einem 17
[Musik]
so leute werden jetzt hinter uns doch
eine und zu sagen wir gehen uns erstmal
in die blaue und die andere riesige
machen wir dann als abschluss
das lustige ist wir haben diese beiden
waren gerade erst gesehen als gedacht
werden jetzt schon alle das war noch gar
nicht reden die sind einfach noch drei
eines geschlossen leider
melde dich mal wieder so gebaut
[Musik]
aber die war schon wieder recht heftig
alle wirklich krass wie viel krasser als
jede in deutschland ist zu heftig so
leute das war's für heute nicht fertig
jetzt sogar schon dunkel man muss sagen
jetzt eigentlich coole aus als im hellen
diese acht waren jetzt in echt krass
[Musik]
leute das was mit dem werk von ist im
achterbahn tag ich glaube es ist der
größte der welt gibt noch nach oben
endlich gefallen hat wir fahren jetzt
zurück und genießen auf ein wenig diese
schöne musik hier online
doch nach oben abonnieren bis morgen
also zschau